Yeah.
A quantum circuit is going to be the unit of value
for your business the cubad is the unit of information
but a circuit is the unit of computation
so let's try to understand what is a quantum circuit
and let's look at its anatomy
this is what a quantum circuit looks
like solicity composes into pieces the cubates
are depicted by these horizontal lines in this case were depicting
a circuit that has four cubits that you see
here shown now the gates are
how we control the cubits
and you read the gates from left to right
and the single cubit gates can be single
cube of gaze or multi cubit gates
you see there the controlled gate
is that one which has the line between two of the cubits
and that's where the entangling operation is gonna happen
and finally you have the measurement and the classical output
and very importantly you run a circuit many times
to get the result with the notion of shots
and so a shot counter which is a number of times
you have to repeat a computation to get the result
well
how do they look
let's look at how a two bit it's like
that i was the picture before right introducing a face change
and i showed before a sea operation that performed that rotation
that allows that to do that interference operation
so let's do a comparison between a classical circuit
and a quantum circuit hearing a classical circuit would you
witness here is that you don't get to see blue moons right
there's no rotations everything here is pink
and that you got the single states
that in these gays were seen windows fear
but notice what a contrast is gonna look
like when we actually implement a quantum circuit
these are the actual circuits that we run in our quantum computers
here that you can try as well
the circuits that we are going to create
with the combination of the gates
generate the full complex amplitude
picture that i shared with you
earlier why is that important
because we can now generate these complex relationships
between the cubits in terms of phases
and entanglement and then through the act of measurement
we are able to collapse this massive amount
of computing that is happening inside into
some important answer
and that is how we get finally to
to the answer so we put inside by side just visually
you can get a sense that a classical circuit can
never exploit the vast computational space
that a quantum circuit can it's
is the best solicitions give you this intuition
of the richness with which we can access this large state.
And the beautiful part of this is that we can
have many classes of circus to
do different functions so
for example this is a circuit
that is designed to model financial risk
he is an example of a circuit
used to search and optimize problems
and here is an example of a circuit that is used to
simulate a molecule an important
take away as that you can design different circuits
for different applications
the circuits that we design are then captured
in software and kept as software
and in our case we keep them in Qiskit
which is our open source development kit for quantum computing
this is one of the most widely used
software frameworks for quantum computing
and you can imagine building
libraries of circuits that get embedded in
classical programs that now combine the best of classical programming
and the best of quantum power